Pour nous parler de cette femme,
qu'elle. Pas les mots de cette
e vous avez apprise à
connaître.
- Je l'ai rencontr
premier foie en 1967. Je l'ai
accompagné à l'occasion des
fêtes de centenaire.
Je l'ai rencontré à deux
occasions comme premier ministre
ou comme ministre.
j'ai passé quatre jours
et demi avec elle, le prince
Philippe la princesse Anne dans
l le Grand Nord ca
c'était intéressant de parler
avec les autochtones, de leurs
travaux et de leur vie.
Elle était très it très it trèsn
parlait et comme j'étais seul
avec elle dans l'a
prince Philippe pensait que
Aline devrait être dans un autre
avion.
J'ai passé des heures avec elle.
Nous parlions en français parcee
occasion pour elle de pratiquer
son français.
C'était la même chose pour le
prince Philippe
parce qu pas autant
l'occasion de parler notre
langue .
Qu'il n'avait eue dans le passé.
J'ai eu des accidents avec elle
et des rencontres aussi bien au
Commonwealth et j'en aiénorméme.
- Elle se tenait au courant et
connaissait les méandres de la
politiqune et des
pièges, des défis et tout ça.
Donc, est-ce qu'elle vous
questionnait... vous sentez
qu'elle suivait le débat
politique au Canada?
- Très bien parce que quand vous
rencontrez la reine et que vous
êtes en Grande-Bretagne. Je l'ai
rencontrée dans quatre châteaux
différents et avant la rencontre
que ce soit pour le lunch, on
doit avoir une rencontre privée
avec la reine où
l'état des affaires du pays qui
fait parti du Commonwealth. Et
quand on avait cette discussion
elle était très au courant.st a,
c'est que j'étais, en 1985, au
moment du référendum, s'étai
fait passer pour Jean Chrétien
et la Russie à la voix sur les
ondes.
Elle avait eu d'propos très
drôle et avec des mots de joual.
Elle avait gardé son calme.
Elle avait répondu dignement et
quand je l'ai vu quelques jours
après à la réunion du
Commonwealth en Nouvelle-
Zélande, je me suis excusé
auprès de la reine : j'ai dit je
me cuise pour ce qui vous est
arrivé l'autre jour.
Il a dit je pensais que vous
étiez ivre.
- Le flegme britannique.
Monsieur
règne on ne verra peut-être plus
jamais ça, c'est quand même une
figure. Elle a élevé la
monarchie à un autre niveau.
On voit les gens tristes à
Londres et même ici au Québec,
il y a des gens qui disent :
sans être monarchisteiais la fe.
- Elle était une femme
extraordinaire.
Était gentille, bien informé et
très agréable.
J'ai eu des souvenirs
extrêmement heureux avec elle et
elle était partout et quand je
voyageais comme premier
ministre, elle était toujours
reçu avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasme et même dans des
endroits qui n'étaient pas
particulièrement monarchistesco,
la réception de la personne
était toujours fantastique.
Quand je voyageais à
l'international, les deux
personnes qui recevaient la
meilleur
elle et Nelson Mandela.
- Ce n'est pas peu dire.
- Quand on était quelque part
avec Nelson Mandela, aucun
d'entre nous n'exister.
Tous les yeux étaient sur Nelson
Mandela et même chose pour la
reine.er à votre
collègut :t :t :t :t :t :t :t ::
dans l'apartheid elle a eu une
influence. D'après vous, elle
voyait les premier ministre
Britannica chaque semaine mais
est-ce qu'elle avait del'influes
que dans son pays d'après vous?
- Certainement mettrait
distraitement.soulève des
problèmes. Elle vous pose des
questions et vous donnez des
réponses. Elle peut dire : êtes-
vous sûr d'être dans la bonne
voie.
J'ai discuté à plusieurs reprisa
avec elle. C'était primordial
elle voulait savoir ce qui se
passait.
Elle faisait des commentaires
Elle avait certainement de
l'influence parce que tout le
monde la respectait.
Et bien, elle était bien
informée et tout ce qu'elle
souhaitait, c'était que les pays
du Commonwealth réussissent.
- Elle a travaillé jusqu'à la